We love them as people, they bring in all sorts of
natural light, they're wonderful to have around, but from a physical security perspective they have some important implications.
What we particularly need to focus on is what is the material that the window is made from, and there's a number of different things that windows can be made from.
Let's start with the cheapest option, plate glass.
Plate glass windows are simple plate glass windows, they're cheap glass.
The defining characteristic of plate glass is that when it breaks, it breaks into big scary shards, not very safe for people, you can get impaled.
So plate glass is the cheapest option, but definitely not the safest.
If you want a safer type of window material, that is tempered glass.
What happens when tempered glass breaks, it breaks into nice little small pebbles, and so you might get little nicks or cuts, but you're not going to get impaled.
So tempered glass, much safer for people.
Wired glass.
Wired glass is glass that has metal wires embedded in it, and I don't know if I just went to like a super sketchy elementary school, but all the windows in the doors in my elementary school had wired glass in them.
The advantage of wired glass is that if the glass breaks, it gets held together by the metal wires, and you still have a barrier there from someone reaching in and undoing the door and on, for instance, because they're still the metal wires that are there.
Laminated glass, as the name implies, the laminated glass is a lamination layers of different materials said which together.
Most commonly you'll have a layer of glass, a layer of plastic, and then another layer of glass.
A really good example of this is windshields and cars.
Oftentimes when you get a rock chip on a car, and if it's in a nicer car, if you go to the outside of the windshield, you'll feel this big rock chip on the window.
But if you go inside the vehicle and you feel in that same spot, there's nothing there.
And that's because a lot of car windshields are actually laminated glass.
There's a layer of glass, a layer of plastic, and then another layer of glass on the inside.
It makes for a much stronger window.
The next type of material is polycarbonate.
And as the name implies, polycarbons, it's actually made out of plastics.
Now you may have heard of this concept of bullet proof glass.
There is actually no such thing as bullet proof glass.
There is bullet resistant glass.
And typically most bullet resistant glass is made out of polycarbons.
And so if you ever get a question asking what's the strongest type of glass, the answer is most definitely polycarbonate.
Now the final thing we should talk about here of the different types of glass is actually not a type of glass but a coating that we can put on the glass.
And they're called solar films.
And solar films, you'll notice this in downtown buildings all the time.
All the buildings that are covered in glass, they're different colors.
Gold, silver, greens.
That's actually different types of solar films that have been applied to the windows.
And the primary reason that we do that is that heat from the sun is a major heating factor in buildings.
And it causes, it would drive up the prices considerably of cooling the building.
And so these solar films actually block UV light, the light that brings in a lot of the heat.
And so from a physical security perspective, we really like solar films because they help reduce the heating load on the building.
And the other thing you can use solar films for is to make what are known as one-way mirrors.
Having spent a lot of time on the wrong side of these, if you've been in an interrogation room, it'll look like a piece of glass from one side.
But on the other side, there's a bunch of police looking at you.
So those are solar films.
The final piece that we'll talk about related to windows is, how do you detect if a window has been broken?
And there's two major types of sensors that you can use to do this.
There's what are known as shock sensors and glass brake sensors.
Glass brake sensors actually listen.
They're essentially a microphone.
And they listen for the specific sound that braking glass makes.
So with a glass brake sensor, you can put like one sensor in a room.
And it'll monitor all the windows in a room.
Shock sensors, on the other hand, are a little sensor that attaches to each individual window.
And a shock sensor actually detects the shock, the vibration of a window being broken.
So here's one final really good question to think about.
Which of these sensors, shock sensors, or glass brake sensors, would be better in a noisy occupied room?
And the answer is shock sensors.
Why?
Well, because shock sensors pick up the vibration of the actual individual window being broken.
Versus glass brake sensors listen for the sound of a window braking.
And in a noisy occupied room, they probably wouldn't be able to detect that sound.
So that's what you need to know about windows.